[Music]  I'll have them do the fish ah I got rid  of them just figured it was for the best  I couldn't get into it you were employed  at the homecoming transitional support  center how do you feel happy what we're  seeking here is information nation what  were your duties there I don't know you  don't know I know why I'm here  I want to be in compliance with all this  compliance have you ever forgotten  something  something big you think you should a  place where they want to help us out  we're here to help them we can leave it  ever we want about your future should  think very carefully  I could take care of them if you want  look  what did she know you're worried aren't  you yes I am  [Music]